مشاهدينا دعونا نرحب بالمصممه هنيده
الصيرفي من عمان اهلا بك يا ندى معنا
هنيده طبعا يعني شو هالاكيد احتفاليه
كبيره ومناسبه
عظيمه وانت طبعا كنت جزء من هذه المناسبه
بهذا التصميم الجميل لفستان ليله الحناء
احكي لنا اكثر عن هذا الفستان لانه شفنا
بعض التفاصيل بالصور كله مشغول يعني
باليد ايضا
صباح الخير والف الف مبروك للانسه رجوى
والاميره الحسين ربنا يتمم لهم بخير ان
شاء الله اكيد انا اشعر بكثير من السعاده
والفخر انه انا اكون جزء من هذا الحدث
التاريخي الجميل لكلنا بنشاركهم فيه من
السعوديه من الاردن واكيد برضو من العالم
العربي
الفستان كان بحكي فيه قصه
تتويج هذا الحب
وانقل فيه هويه
ادمج فيه الهويه ما بين الهويه السعوديه
والهويه الاردنيه من ناحيه الازياء
والثقافه اكيد كمان طبعا كنت حابه اوصل في
شخصيه الانسه رجوى الشخصيه اللطيفه
الحيويه الجميله اللي ساعدت بالتعرف عليها
من خلال هذا التعاون
وطبعا شاكر لهم لدعوتي لحضور حفل الحنه
اكيد طبعا حاولت اننا استعمل اللي كان
معروف بالثوب النجدي الثوب السحابي وهو من
الازياء
[موسيقى]
خليني خليني اعرف ما هي المواد ممكن يحكي
عن هذا الفستان
هناك ارتباط جغرافي بين المملكه العربيه
السعوديه والاردن لكن ايضا بودي ان اتساءل
ماذا عن المواد المستخدمه لصناعه هذا
الفستان مما هو مصنوع ولماذا يعني كان
بهذه الاختيارات
طيب اهم حاجه كان عنده ان انا احول هذا
التوب
تراثي اطوره بحيث انه هو يناسب شخصيه
الانسه بتحاكي في بنات جيلها استعملنا فيه
طبعا الخيوط الذهبيه
خيوط الحرير خيوط القصب والكنتيل هذه كلها
خيوط برضو مشهوره
في الاثواب النجديه طبعا برضه كان في
رسومات كثير من الرسومات
النباتيه والزخارفه العربيه وكذلك برضه
الاشكال الهندسيه التي ترمز الى جبال
الاردن وجبال السعوديه كانت كلها عباره عن
فرح كلها عباره عن عن توصيل يعني هذا
الزواج المبارك ان شاء الله
لمتابعتي المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات